mariani bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors les
dirigeants européens se retrouvent dans
quelques heures pour une nouvelle fois
se coordonner pour éviter une troisième
vague c'est en ordre dispersé que les
vingt-sept affronte actuellement le
regain de lecture de nous écouter quand
on voit ce sommet on s'aperçoit que la
vraie préoccupation c'est pas l'épidémie
en réalité c'est comment se servir de
l'épidémie pour faire avancer
l'idéologie d'une partie des
responsables européens
soyons clairs d'abord ce qui se joue à
bruxelles est extrêmement grave c'est à
dire qu'on a et je pèse mes mots un
sommet de maître chanteur de maître
chanteur et monsieur macro ont fait
partie de ces maîtres chanteurs qui
disent voilà vous avez que vous acceptez
désormais ce qu'on veut sinon désormais
vous n'aurez plus dead est donc le
premier sommeil avait marché pourquoi
parce qu'en réalité on avait dit voilà
il ya un plan dette avec une telle
répartition mais là on dit ah oui mais
la répartition on va vous la faire mais
à condition que vous acceptez ce qu'on
veut dans des sujets qui n'ont rien à
voir avec la crise de la santé et moi je
dis bravo à monsieur rebattre bravo à la
pologne bravo à la slovénie
parce que c'est peut-être eux qui sort
en train de sauver l'europe aujourd'hui
en réalité sous prétexte de vouloir
créer l'europe de la santé de sauver les
citoyennes qu'est ce qu'on veut
qu'est-ce qu'on veut imposer
et bien cette commission ce parlement
européen dit tout simplement vous devrez
accepter ce qu'on souhaite en matière
d'état de droit
formule totalement imprécises mais hélas
aussi la hongrie la pologne et la
slovénie ont raison ça consiste en fait
à dire vous devrez accepter au niveau de
l'immigration ce qu'on souhaite vous
devrez accepter au niveau de l'évolution
des moeurs ce qu'on souhaite
bref c'est en réalité un sommet je pèse
mes mots de maître chanteur qui veulent
imposer la dictature de leur valeur à la
totalité des pays justement fut manque
de coordination
c'est le symbole d'un dysfonctionnement
de mieux selon vous non c'est pas du
tout un manque de coordination
c'est en réalité je le répète j'aime le
premier marché one a dit voilà on va
s'entendre pour un plan pour aider les
économies et faire redémarrer et tout le
monde a dit d'accord et puis à ce
deuxième sommet on dit ah oui mais pour
quand vous donne deux
argent à tous ses états il faut que vous
acceptiez désormais ce que demande de
l'union européenne dans toute une série
de domaines
c'est pour ça que je pèse mes mots et
c'est pas un excès c'est du chantage du
chantage ou on dit à ses états et bien
voilà accepter l'état de droit et l'état
de droit ça veut dire quoi pour eux
parce qu'en réalité c'est une formule
très vague
ça veut dire par exemple que quand la
pologne décide de changer par légalement
c'est son droit
son système au niveau de l'organisation
judiciaire l'europe d'hier adore quand
la hongrie dit à l'ats nous on veut pas
accepter d'avoir nos frontières ouvertes
l'europe dira non s'ils n'ont pas
l'argent quand la slovénie dit pareil on
veut préserver un certain système qui
est l'originalité de notre nation
l'europe dira non donc on parle très peu
de ce sommet européen et je vous en
remercie mais pour moi c'est peut-être
le sommet le plus grave de ces cinq
dernières années
parce qu'en réalité le les technocrates
et je pèse mes mots la commission
européenne essaie d'avancer
sournoisement pour imposer son plan
alors on a le sentiment que c'est la
chancelière allemande et la présidence
allemande de trouver la solution de
trouver ce déblocage
quelle est l'issue possible selon vous
car on ne voit pas où trouver un
compromis finalement écouté d'abord
l'issue possible ce serait de respecter
les nations c'est à dire que chacun est
souverain chez soi en ce qui concerne
l'organisation judiciaire alors que hank
en ce qui concerne par exemple le
l'acceptation ou non de certains
réfugiés ou de certains migrants voilà
on voit aujourd'hui qu'on a une
tentative dopé à de l'allemagne sur
l'europe
moi je suis nouveau député européen j'ai
été 25 ans député français j'avoue que
je suis halluciné du fonctionnement de
ce parlement je croyais que c'était un
parlement comme les autres n'ont en
réalité c'est un parlement qui doit
avaliser toute une série de décisions
avec une partie de mes collègues et je
pèse mes mots qui n'ont jamais été élus
sur leurs dents qui sont simplement élus
sur des listes à la proportionnelle et
qui sont là pour faire avancer un agenda
de leur parti politique qui est collée à
l'europe et donc en réalité aujourd'hui
on voit que de plus en plus c'est une
europe qui colle aux intérêts allemands
malheureusement avant on avait ce ce duo
qui marche
et à peu près franco-allemand
aujourd'hui soyons honnête il ne marche
plus parce que pour qui un duo il faut
que les deux soient à puissance
équivalente
la gestion catastrophique de monsieur
macron et avant celle de hollande mais
la gestion du coc vite par monsieur
macro et pire mais va mettre la france à
genoux en matière économique
l'allemagne va s'en sortir beaucoup
mieux que nous et on voit désormais que
l'europe est en réalité une europe qui
est dirigée par l'allemagne pour ses
intérêts regardez ce qui s'est passé
pour l'immigration
en réalité c'est madame merkel qui a
imposé ses frontières ouvertes il ya
quatre ans et qui aujourd'hui veut
imposer une immigration forte parce que
l'industrie allemande en a besoin
regardez la politique étrangère de
l'europe on se couche en permanence face
à la turquie pourquoi parce que la
turquie vous connaissez désormais le
poids de l'électorat turc en allemagne
et les relations entre la turquie et
l'allemagne depuis des années bref
aujourd'hui on a une europe allemande
qui essayent d'imposer ses règles et ce
sommet capital et je pense que tous les
français qui sont attachés à leurs
spécificités leurs nations devraient
suivre avec intérêt la résistance de ces
trois pays hongrie pologne slovénie
parce que peut-être que dans quelques
années on dira que c'est eux qui nous
ont sauvés questions concernant l la
pandémie elle-même on a l'impression qu'
il n'y a toujours pas d'approché commune
entre les pays où on a vu que certains
pays ont décidé de fermer leurs
frontières d'autres ont instauré par
exemple des politiques de test ou
différentes quarantaine chacun navigue à
vue est ce que l'union européenne
finalement n'a plus la main aujourd'hui
sur la question des déplacements entre
autres trois remarques
d'abord la première on vous dit l'union
européenne n'a pas la compétence de la
santé c'est vrai est aujourd'hui dans ce
sommet quand vous lisez les propos de
certains commissaires ils vous disent
là-bas il faut créer désormais une
europe de la santé donc une fois de plus
sur un sujet vous apercevez que l'europe
se sert de la crise pour essayer d'avoir
de plus en plus de compétences et dans
plus en plus en biais t sur les sur
l'état et sur les différents états et
leurs compétences
deuxième remarque avec le sourire c'est
extraordinaire je me suis je les dis on
n'a pas de compétence en matière de
santé mais si je vous dis stella
kyriakides s vous allez réfléchir et me
dire qu'ils se
je vais vous aider c'est en réalité la
commissaire à la santé c'est à dire que
l'europe elle tellement sur
l'administration qu'on avait créé bienne
avant la crise du côté du co vite pardon
une commissaire à la santé qui en
réalité n'avait pas de compétence
alors est-ce que je pense que l'europe
doit se donner plus de compétences en
doigt ce que donnait plus de
coordination mais très sincèrement
regardé en france on en est à dire qu'il
faut gérer la situation au plus près du
terrain la situation à marseille c'est
pas la même que celle à paris c'est pas
la même que celle à nice et donc moi
quand je vois que les pays prennent des
mesures différentes
ça ne me choque pas parce que la
situation en lituanie en pologne au
portugal ou en france c'est pas la même
donc il faut laisser aux états le soin
de régler ce genre de deux situations en
fonction de la situation sanitaire de
des différentes régions par contre ce
que je regrette c'est que nos frontières
au sein de l'espace schengen sont
totalement ouvertes et que là par contre
si on veut que chaque état puisse
maîtriser la situation il faut des
frontières qui se puissent être
contrôlés aujourd'hui il faut choisir où
un as des frontières fermées pour chaque
est fermé aux femmes contrôlées pour
chaque état et une gestion par l'état au
plus près du terrain
c'est ce que je souhaite c'est ce que
souhaite le rassemblement national où on
a un entre deux qui en réalité abouti à
rien c'est à dire des frontières
ouvertes et une gestion où chacun fait
un peu ce qu'il veut malheureusement une
fois de plus l'europe a pris la mauvaise
voie
merci beaucoup thierry mariani et
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions j'aurais je rappelle que vous
êtes député hors pair du rassemblement
national